hello welcome to this video playing
megas at that wow I've got I have never
won against him with the chess explained
account definitely with others but yeah
for losses two drawers it's pretty awful
let me share quickly what's the name
it's got a Chinese sounding name that is
from Australia song you want our okay
yeah Queen d3 is the line that I don't
like four white [ __ ] let's see what
happens
yeah you can go the a Quincy to as the
normal just wondering Queenie 394 23
said the draw not quite sure if I can
avoid the drawdown yeah this is this is
this line I think it's very ok for black
the sea for corn and the pawns in
general there are weak but I have not
given up my my dark squared Bishop which
is which is a good a good thing because
I let me think about it here since your
castles or I don't have to cover b7 of
course
just wondering about castles Bishop f4
Queen 67 there is 95 that's not a good
idea I cannot just castle can he
cancelled quickly
can't remember d6
when I it's not be five now a problem
Quincy 496 huh maybe I should have
thought about this for a moment yeah I
plant that a bit too quickly and add
alternatives to the move I think okay
but now I basically have to take I have
forgotten my analysis here absolutely
yeah Queenie to looks looks shaky
hmm
yeah the check that looks wrong ok I can
do no 93 maybe 93 what is C playing then
rock the tool when i get some some huge
chunks of material on there look at you
two I want to go neither form
I get there I get bishop Brooke and two
pawns for the queen with with bad
development admittedly oh I didn't think
about this move I should have I really
should have hmm ok so Queen cheeks
doesn't do any good and we have to check
yeah and again I'm giving up the Queen
yeah I really have to just wanted to
check that I really have to do it but
check okay and let's see now I've got
night into the pawn if I take them now
look look Texas is wrong so i have to
take with this yeah that's the issue a
little bit let's keep it
yeah it's not easy it's not so easy foam
I think
oopsie 8 next
he has no clear way of activating of
activating his rook the night is doing a
decent job down putting everything on
dark squares that should help so is
there any way for me to improve my
position I could play Bishop defined if
I ever set instead an idea that is
interesting okay so check the a3 pawn if
I get the I can take a five ah shoot
okay maybe roocase Evan was good then
but I on bishops III okay okay okay
couldn't he couldn't have taken the pond
okay so that looks dangerous for him he
and what would you have six I think my
pieces coordinate well now
that looks nice now really nice I think
it was probably a bit too ambitious
check understandably I mean if you win
the Queen you want to win the game but
at the time morning yeah Luke ph is
getting checkmated so there is no threat
down I don't say okay sticker with this
maybe just h4
yeah objectively I'm winning here now
perfectly coordinated pieces
yes almost it's pretty awkward ok this
one it's not threatening to take Queen
gphi office and threat maybe but okay i
think i can i can check now check check
should be her maid actually check check
check check mate well that was beautiful
that was really nice i stumbled into
this of course i mean i had some issues
and had to sacrifice the queen but it
worked out beautifully probably because
he made some kind of mistake i forgot
the precise move on here queen bee three
years this is right i think but i'm not
sure about g6 now i would really have to
look it up in my head by the own book
let's do that actually i mean i have a
have a copy here let's let's check I'd
really like to night you know what I had
recommended let's see
mmm castles Quincy 7 there are castles
Quincy 7s right okay so i should go
queen c7 push about 46 needs to the main
line yeah so i keep forgetting my own
analysis so don't worry if you forget
what you probably read in my book like
forget it myself okay I hadn't really
have no idea about this position that
this just pretty crazy so what is some
the engine giving get engine wants to
just take catch a check here King age 1
and then play the move b6 hmm hmm that's
very cold-blooded
it's very tough move for a human to play
especially when you and you have no time
to figure it out this for example looks
pretty dangerous check yeah but it seems
that I have 85 and this is this is
keeping things check under control black
equalizers 93 9 28 yeah the engine gives
us this gently equal which which might
be true I mean might be true my
coordination is really okay I do I don't
see a way forward for him but of course
it doesn't have to do said that's pretty
clear this is this g4 was probably not a
great idea well here I've no they formed
just win stuff okay i didn't i didn't
think about a tactical move like that
let's say i was just thinking about
optimizing my piece coordination yeah
like here bishop d4 and d5 he's mostly
shuffling what has no idea me five and
i'd be five year i was this this was a
happy I am that was a bit lucky I didn't
really see a five hangs and so there's
this and hear the engine already gives
me a pretty big advantage yeah yeah the
computer wants to take a 4-bit now know
that is that you have to check look at
the king here and the king is the the
main yeah the main nerve and target /
tech of horsham here get here and check
I'm
eating him already one stay away for him
to avoid the meat I have King edge true
okay check check check check mate very
nice there was a nice one very very
satisfying way to to win to win a game
here with that funny mate giving her the
Queen fall to pieces and the pawn is
some always attractive to do if it works
out okay thanks for watching